foreign
fashion is incredibly fascinating
because it's an expression of yourself
but how many of us today morning
have consciously thought about the
clothes that you have worn and the
impact that it creates
take a moment think about it this cute
t-shirt that you're wearing
has costed this planet 3000 liters of
polluted water
which is around 4.4
years of drinking water per person
if you think about it every time you
wear clothes you're actually becoming an
accomplice of the world's second most
polluting industry
we are speaking about
2700 billion metric tons of carbon
emissions per year
25 percent of the global chemical
production 20 percent of the industrial
water pollution and these numbers just
get scarier
but I am not here today to scare you
uh not really
instead in the form of Indian hand looms
that is Indian handmade textiles I am
here to give you a solution which is
sustainable
immensely fashionable affordable
and scalable
I was born
in family
where we work with Artisans across India
since the age of five my father would
take me across these various artisanal
clusters and that's where my love for
craftsmanship blossomed
having run two Indian handloom companies
and working with thousands of Artisans
across the geography of India today I
bring to you greetings from the world's
oldest
and largest sustainable fashion clothing
industry
now let's look at how these Artisans or
Heroes perhaps are solving some of the
most concerning problems of fashion
industry today
for that you have to travel along with
me to my country India and meet Padma
Amma Padma Amma is a 61 year old Handler
Madison and has been working for the
last four decades
let's look at the Fabrics which padmama
uses
see all of us we think about plastic in
our cups very good plastic in a straws
awesome
what about plastic in your clothes
70 of today's fashion is made out of
plastic
Padma Amma on the other hand uses
biodegradable Fabrics
hand looms are ecological textiles what
it essentially means is by the end of
their shelf life they will also leave
this planet just like we humans do
next up is Seasons fashion today
operates on the model of Seasons that is
what is relevant today is not relevant
six to seven months from today
now Padma Amma creates seasonless
fashion what is essentially means that
fashion which is beyond the clutches of
Seasons colors Trends unimaginable right
but true
so what it essentially means is what you
buy five years ago is relevant today
will be relevant 10 years from now
in a sense it is timeless
next you can ask me hey
does this hand Loom even have the
longevity to last this long
for that the answer is yes
clothes today especially three out of
five clothes are lining up straight to
the landfill within 12 months of its
production because of lowering
production quality
Indian hand Looms on the other hand have
a quality which is like fine wine the
more the age the more beautiful they
become how
it's because of the immense amount of
talent of these Artisans and the
complexity of these weeds which no AI in
the world can replicate
now from climate sustainability let's
move on for sustainability for the
people
employs 60 women from a village she also
runs a school in a village
now here's a woman who's showing the
world that it is possible
to balance craft Commerce and
sustainability all at the same time
we are living in a world where AI is
constantly replacing human beings
leading to massive layoffs and here I am
telling you that hand looms has the
capacity to create jobs and more
importantly create entrepreneurs
now at this point you could think Fair
we understood we bought your
argument that these guys are sustainable
okay but your question could be are they
fashionable
can they understand my fashion my
creative urge and desire
for that let me take you to the epitome
of sorry epitome of fashion and that's
kuthir the textbook definition of kuthir
is high fashion high quality
customized product hand spun right from
start to finish
concentrate on the last line hand spun
from scratch to finish
isn't that the definition of Indian hand
looms too
we are speaking about creating fashion
about creating kuthir and democratizing
it for the world
how Let's Travel to eastern part of
India and meet gopaldas gopal Das has
created till date 10 000 pieces of
garments and no two garments are same
each of them are unique as unique as
Leaf of a tree flake of a snow
and with this
now you look at the sari this yellow
dress that red gown
that beautiful red skirt
and the red dress
all of these have one thing in common
all of them are Indian handlooms
the point that I want you to understand
is these Artisans are geniuses
they have talent which has been passed
down to them generation after generation
and so they can cater to every single
requirement of the fashion industry
they can create the products as per the
industry demands what they only require
is a chance
not charity but opportunity
and if you think about affordability
well handlums can give you a handcrafted
shirt for less than thirty dollars
something which when you wear you'll ha
your heart will feel will be filled with
pride
because every product has a story to
tell and at the same time Indian
handlooms gives you the most expensive
Fabrics in the world
in a sense there is something for
everyone
now
we have spoken about sustainability we
have also spoken about
fashion we have spoken about
affordability but at this point your
question could be is there scale
are there people
overlaying to adopt or cater to the
demands of the industry and the answer
to that is
4.4 million
today Indian hand looms have an
employment size of 4.4 million Artisans
and just like any other industry when
there is growth there is more production
there are more orders this industry is
also bound to grow
now
in the last seven minutes I took your
cross India let me get you back to this
room where all of us are right now and
think about how we can create a
sustainable ecosystem
so let's start with the fashion brands
and designers now you guys have the
power of creation
you have you are the Creative Source so
it's your responsibility to pair up with
these Artisans and create sustainable
fashion
sustainable fashion in every sense of
the word
now the next up are celebrities
okay so Lady Gaga if you're listening to
this please
you have the power of influence
so when you can get Indian handlooms and
handlooms in general into the mainstream
the world will start adopting it you can
make candles look cool
right and with that the artisanal
Community now across the globe is
eagerly waiting to see you in an
authentic handloom ensembly
and you guys
consumers last but not the least you
have the most important power the power
of the purse
so when you start demanding conscious
choices to the fashion industry fashion
can no longer ignore you it will have to
succumb to your demand and give you
sustainable Fabrics
with all of this
this moment handlooms will have a
trickling effect so we are not just
speaking about handloom artisans in
India but this will have a Domino's
effect in countries like Pakistan
Nigeria Kenya Malaysia Thailand America
Japan Brazil and the likes
let's work together and make an
ecosystem where
we can preserve our ancient Technologies
while preserving our Collective Global
heritage
and getting that balance between
Commerce craft sustainability and
fashion
let's make a world where fashion is good
for the wearer
good for the Mecca and good for the
planet
thank you
[Music]